so thank you everyone for joining today
welcome to the free webinar on
metagenomics where we will be discussing
microbiome and its role in precision
medicine in
this online program we will explore the
amazing role of microbes
that we can see in human well-being
health and diseases this webinar is for
students and researchers
and will cover the aspects of
metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna and other aspects
of microbiology
research using bioinformatics
i want to now introduce you to the
program speakers
we have elia brodsky our ceo and
co-founder at buying biotech
in his current role he has extensive
experience
working together with industry and
academic partners that are applying
multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics to a
variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
dr hartreet kaur is our certified omits
logic trainer and expert by information
who will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist the participants with projects
and analysis
during our upcoming training programs
her area of specialization is cancer
genomics and machine learning
and dr mohit masundar is our omits logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with industry and academia i now
want to invite
elia to conduct the session
and take over the session today elia
over to you
thank you sir and let me share my
screening
hello and welcome to this free webinar
i'm excited to see all of you
participating today and i hope that what
we will share today will give you
a greater insight into metagenomics
itself and also hope to introduce some
of the materials and resources that we
will be making available
in this upcoming program so as beeps
mentioned metagenomics is a new and
exciting way
to study microorganisms in their natural
environment
and so this approach allows us to really
dissect microbial community structures
but we have to also be mindful of the
way that the data is generated
and how it is used in the analysis
now these communities or microbiota
allow us to understand how different
microorganisms coexist
shape their environment and develop a
relationship
with the host we can study this
microbiota to explore species richness
and investigate the functional roles
that these
microbial communities play in many areas
related to human health
and disease
so in this webinar what you will learn
about is
the upcoming omics logic metagenomics
program
that will be starting on november 17th
this online program is designed to be
equally rewarding to both
students that are just starting to learn
about metronomics
and researchers that are already
involved in
microbial research and it is especially
suited
for project based learning on a flexible
schedule so we will combine
a number of different elements to really
facilitate a flexible schedule
that would make it available around the
world and
will make it possible for you to
continue and apply these tools and
methods to your own research
the program itself will cover main
aspects of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s ribosomal rna
and other aspects of microbiology
research using
bioinformatics at the end of the program
all of the participants can opt out
for independent or group research
projects
in other words you can apply the
understanding
of theoretical concepts and the
practical tools
to data sets that we will help you find
and
curate so we have prepared a number of
examples but you can expand on those
and apply bioinformatics tools that are
accessible to those that
do not have any technical background
don't have any coding background
and for those that want to learn how to
code we will provide you with tools
and guidance on how to use those tools
using
our python and past scripting
at the end of the program when you have
prepared your project proposal or maybe
conducted a full preliminary research
proposal
we will connect you with an expert that
will help you
evaluate the project idea and
potentially develop a competitive
proposal
that you can continue and work on after
the program is over
so what we're hoping is that the
majority of you joining today
will enjoy hearing about metagenomics
and where the field of microbiome is
going
as well as utilize some of the resources
that we plan to make available
this month so for those of you that are
interested to learn more
in the program itself i'm just going to
ask beeps if you could
put the metagenomics omixlogic.com link
in the chat box and as we go through
this program you can explore some of the
details of the program itself
now in all of our armature logic
training programs
we combine online interactive sessions
kind of like what we're going to be
doing today self-guided study materials
that i will
briefly touch upon and practical
assignments that you can
run analysis and understand what goes
into the different types of sequencing
analysis methods
processing pipelines and visualization
tools all together this creates an
immersive experience that we are focused
on developing
to provide excellent training in
bioinformatics now what we have found
is that many elements together become
an effective tool for thousands of
students that we have worked with over
the years
and that have completed the onyx logic
training programs
to launch them into the field of
bioinformatics so even if you're coming
from a biotechnology biology or life
science programs
this is the way for you to start
incorporating bioinformatics into your
expertise
which is a highly demanded skill set
in any area of life science research
in today's session i am going to focus
on metagenomics
speaking mostly about the bioinformatics
analysis of metagenomic sequencing data
these methods for processing analysis
and visualization of metagenomics data
include
detailed tutorials on the use of such
popular approaches like
kind 2 data 2 and phylocy
so these are different types of
processing and visualization tools
that we will briefly touch on today but
we will speak in much greater detail
in the program that will start november
17th
but before we begin talking about
bioinformatics
let's see how sequencing technology has
helped
develop this whole field of microbiome
research
and has provided an effective view
into the study of microorganisms
and how these data analysis tools
developed for metagenomic studies
are used today to characterize
microbiota
and allow us to ask important questions
about these microbial communities
and how they develop and evolve in
association with other phenotypic
conditions that we can characterize
since the discovery of the microscope
humans have been learning about
microorganisms that surround us
and as the resolution of these
microscopes improved more import
more and more representatives of the
unseen world have been discovered
the scale of optical resolution can
reveal details of up to
one micrometer which is a typical size
of a bacteria
today microscopes are tremendously
powerful allowing us
to see smaller and smaller elements that
reveal
how the world of microorganisms
functions on
every imaginable surface and importantly
how microorganisms actively interact
with each other so in this image
you can see a super high resolution
achieved with helium ion technology
that shows the process of bacteriophages
which are
green right here so these green
dots are bacteriophages that are
attacking
e coli bacteria the blue are the e coli
bacteria
so you can see how this interaction is
happening in real life just because
just between two members of this
community of microbiome community
microbiota
representing a virus or a phage and
a bacteria now the connection between
disease and microorganisms has
been established in the 1800s and
already towards the end of the 19th
century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms
in a lab culture were developed helping
characterize them
with staining these studies provided
important information about bacterial
function
in isolation however it was soon
apparent that
most microorganisms in fact live in
complex communities
and it was soon discovered that many
members of these communities
are actually not possible to culture in
isolation in a lab
so today we know that the microorganisms
or the microbiota
in collection that make up the human
microbiome
are not just unicellular organisms
living alongside each other but instead
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
attached to surfaces as biofilms with
inter-species collaborations
as well as antagonisms that contribute
to
its ecological stability
due to the advances in metagenomic
sequences
sequencing and other omix technologies
and enormous databases of sequencing
data
from such communities has led to the
emergence of computational metagenomics
which can help study the remaining 99
of uncultured unculturable
microorganisms in the context of their
natural environment so you can see here
a brief timeline
how in the mid 1600s
first observations of microscopic
organisms
were published and then the connection
has been made between disease
and microorganisms and then from
the 1800s until now this
practice of staining and microscopy has
been used
to study different isolated
microorganisms
eventually in the 1980s unculturable
microorganisms
are started were started to be studied
using dna sequencing
in 2008 an important milestone actually
started in 2007
the human microbiome project was
launched and has provided as we will see
in the future slides
an expansive database of sequences of
different microorganisms
and so starting from 2010 up until now
so the past decade
and onward we are seeing the important
and critical
role of bioinformatics or computational
biology tools
to study the communities in the context
of this
era of multi-omics data sets
now the stability of these communities
is fascinating as many of us probably
know from trying to battle such common
skin conditions as
eczema acne and dry skin
these communities form distinct
communities
the micro organisms in a microbiota are
interconnected
and determined to maintain their
community
bacteria within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and
responding to small diffusible signal
molecules
in a process called quorum sensitivity
which confirms benefit for host
colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors
and adaptation to changes in the
environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved in the virulence
and pathogenic potential of bacteria and
are therefore
an important factor in understanding and
controlling bacterial infections
as they enable microorganisms and
biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses and
antimicrobial agents
so inside each community there's a
balance in fact of bacteria
fungi and viruses and together they
control species abundance
and the activity of that particular
microbiota
the human microbiota is estimated to be
10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th of
microbial cells
so trillions of cells with around one to
one microbial cells to human cells ratio
even though it was previously reported
that there is a much greater number of
microorganisms about
one to ten these figures have been
updated not so long ago by standard out
in 2016.
these numbers are derived from the total
bacterial cells
in colon which is 3.8 to the 10 to the
13th of bacteria
the organ that harbors the densest
number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries
an important functional property in
genes that contain
genomic information on metabolites and
proteins that these microorganisms
produce
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms
have been a growing interest to the
scientific community
resulting in over eighty thousand
publications over the years
the majority of these studies have been
focused on the intestinal microbiome
but more and more additional
relationships between
the composition of microbiota and
different conditions
has been emerging since the 1990s
microbiome studies were significantly
advanced
through such major initiatives as the
metagenomics of the human intestinal
tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project these are
tremendous huge investments and studies
that have been made possible
through the advances in metagenomic
sequencing so as a result skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota are
starting to be characterized in great
detail
each new project represents vast
opportunities
as well as challenges to determine which
microorganisms
play key roles in the development of
certain environmental conditions
needed for healthy function of human
organs and which can be actually harmful
to such communities over the past decade
more than 1.7 billion has been spent
on human microbiome research major
projects are underway
in the united states european union
china canada ireland south korea and
japan
this investment has confirmed the
importance of microbiome to human health
and development
it is now known for instance that
newborns receive
essential microorganisms from their
mothers
moreover the sugars in breast milk that
infants cannot digest
nourish babies developing microbiomes
which in turn shape their immune systems
the biggest investment by far around one
billion dollars
came from the united states about 20
percent of this
has gone to two phases of the human
microbiome projects
you can see right here which is creating
the research resources
needed for studying the human microbiome
one of the main goals of the human
microbiome project launched in 2007
was to create a toolbox of reference
data sets
computational techniques analytical
methods and clinical protocols
this seems to have been a major success
about 75 percent
of the 2012 to 2016 nih grant recipients
for microbiome research outside of the
hmp
is working on more than 100 different
diseases
this cited reliance on hmp data
and tools in their funding applications
so it's becoming clear
that microbes are needed to support
human development and maturation
and to activate and maintain stability
in the immune system and metabolism
but there are still many things that we
don't understand for example we don't
understand how these fundamental
biological phenomena involving
human cells and microbes co-evolved
what's even more important some
ecological concepts
are not yet commonly considered in the
studies of the human microbiome
these include how communities of
microbes operate
as a whole how keystone species
can pave the way for others by altering
local conditions
and the predator prey relationships
between different microbes
developing a new conceptual framework
and applying it to the human microbiome
will require
much more collaboration between
investigators working
across desperate fields including
evolution
ecology microbiology biomedicine
and computational biology or
bioinformatics
it will also demand significant changes
in how data and other resources are
distributed between scientists
and importantly it will require a good
communication between
those coming from the computational
field those coming from the
health sciences field and those coming
from basic research
because right now these are very
separate
areas of microbiome research and we see
that they all interrel interrelate
allowing many of these findings to come
and be tested and become clinically
important so
we know today that the microbiome
function
is important for many areas of human
development
health and disease and it's because of
this huge investment of capital
and human research time that we now know
that the endogenous human microbial
communities
contribute to critical metabolic
physiological
and immunological functions that include
differentiation maturation of the host
mucosa
and its immune system food digestion
and nutrition energy generation
metabolic regulation and
control of fat storage processing
and detoxification on the environmental
chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function
development and regulation of the immune
system and fine
tuning of its reaction pattern or the
balance between pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory processes and the
prevention
of invasion and growth of
disease-promoting microorganisms
for example colonization resistance
so an important underlying technology
that connects many of these studies
are being answered using next generation
sequencing
as well as other types of omics data for
example
mass spectroscopy proteomics and
metabolics indeed it seems that
the future the next phase of prominent
microbiome research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets that combine
next generation sequencing mass spec and
structural data
with phenotypic information about
overall changes
in the community and their environment
so to understand the challenges
and the changing nature of such data
let's take a look
at some of this data and how it could be
integrated
so here we can see an approach to
integration
where you can see the immune system and
health
indicators being studied in the response
to different types of treatments
so you can study the before and after
and
time course conditions to understand how
samples different types of microbes
and their changes over time and you can
study that
using dna sequencing rna sequencing so
the expression of specific genes
metaproteinomics or which proteins are
actually being produced and how they
interrelate to each other and
importantly
metabolize sequences or sorry
metabolites
so all of this has to be integrated
using
data integration approaches that look at
the detailed
structured data sets and then finding
network associations which you can see
right here
between the different species and the
products of their
function this is an important and
emerging area
of my multi-omics integration
that has to do with precision medicine
which is really becoming an important
part of many areas of omnics research
so i'm going to pause right now and take
a look at some of the questions that i
see in the chat
and answer any of the questions that you
might have
about what we have done up until now
okay so if you have any questions and if
you could
help me identify any questions that have
already been
posed i'm uh ready to answer
any questions that people might have
right now okay yes celia so we have one
from modibo
he's asking i'm working about autism i
would like to know the specific
microbiomes associated to autism
okay so modibu thank you for the
question um indeed
autism and other neurodegenerative
diseases have been linked to different
indicators i think what's important
to understand is that many of such
studies are
in their early stages and one of the
things that you can derive from data
sets that are already available
are some associations now association is
not
necessarily causality and so that's one
of the things where we will talk about
in a few
slides from now we will be talking about
how
such causal
associations could be studied using
animal modeling
so we will talk about animal models of
human microbiome composition
and how those have been used to study
different
psychological neurodegenerative diseases
thank you elia we have another question
from shraddha
my area of research is breast cancer how
can i study microbiome in relation to it
or the influence of it in breast cancer
okay excellent question so in fact
breast cancer and other
cancers have been linked to tumor
micro environment there are many
publications on these topics but also
importantly
how the microbiome is affected by
different types of chemotherapy and
targeted therapy
because many of the functions of the
immune response are linked to microbiome
many of the cancer treatments are
related to the immune response
so those are important areas of research
now we're not going to definitively
answer these questions
in this short presentation but in the
course of the upcoming program
what we will do is we will take these
data sets and publications that present
the
evidence from sequencing data and you
will be able to analyze those data to
find such association so i think if that
is an
interest i will definitely point today
to how to easily find such data sets
and what are some of the common tools
that are used to find
such associations
thank you so much elia and if you have
any specific
projects that you are going to work on i
just want to take one minute
you can actually reach out to us at
marketing at pine dot bio
for any such queries and we will be able
to help you out because
uh it's not always possible to address
all the questions in this one
uh session uh either for the next
question we have one from nepal
are these networks a part of network
pharmacology
okay excellent question so this will be
the last question for now i'll
move on after this but network
pharmacology
seeks to establish how specific
active compounds can affect
the overall systems biology which of
course works as a network or could be
represented by a network
of nodes that are interrelated by the
edges in the network
studying such networks and the changes
in the networks
is a field of its own that allows us to
understand how
the perturbations of the network can
help reveal
some of these prominent and strong
associations
so what we will be talking about today
are some general approaches to such
types of data integration and analysis
in bioinformatics and it could
definitely be applied to
pharmacological studies as well where
you take essentially
drugs combinations of drugs different
dosages apply them to different
individuals and then study how those
are change how the responses of those
individuals are changing
because of their for example microbiome
or microbiome host
pathogen relationships how do those
actually are affected
so we won't talk about this topic in
detail right now
but we will definitely expand on such
studies
in the context of the program now in
uh in the current presentation i'm going
to move on for right now
please continue posting your questions
on the chat we will pause for another
few minutes
after a few more slides to address some
of the changes
sorry some of the questions that you
have
posted in the chat so thank you for your
questions
so let's talk a little bit about one
types of one type of such data
metagenomics obviously metagenomics
is a predominant technique used to study
microbiome because it allows us to study
the sequences now metagenomics as a
field
can be defined as the genomic analysis
of microbial dna
from environmental communities
metagenomics tools
enable the population analysis of
unculturable or previously unknown
microbes
this is very important because only one
to two percent of bacteria can be
actually cultured
in the lab the ability to identify
microbes without a priori knowledge of
what
sample contains is opening new doors in
disciplines
like microbial ecology virology
microbiology environmental sciences and
many areas of biomedical research
sequencing based examination of the
metagenome
has become a powerful tool for
generating novel hypotheses
now metagenomics as opposed to other
types of omics really represents
a different approach for example
genomics
proteomics transcriptomics all focused
on whole of a single organisms
but metagenomics allow us to study a
collection of
organisms that live in communities and
interact so we're really when we are
approaching
the question from a metagenomics
perspective
we are looking at how the community
composition
diversity is changing in response
to different types of phenotypic data
metagenomic sequencing itself can be
applied
to environmental culture free sequencing
to study populations
as well as for detailed extraction of
genomic variation
and the expression of genes from the
microorganisms
after culturing in the lab and
oftentimes when we speak about
metagenomics
we are speaking about those two
technologies actually combined together
so here you can see on top an example of
you taking a sample from the gut
and then looking at culture free
sequencing reads where we can
look at otus which i'll speak about in a
second here
to understand taxonomic classification
now importantly in some examples you can
take and culture
some dominant species or representatives
of this community
to then map onto the reference genome
and understand variation
in those types of sequences so for
example we can discover
how antibiotic resistance how changes
in the specific function of the genes
produced by the most abundant species in
the microbiome
could be linked to this taxonomic
classification
to understand how the whole community
is affected by such changes
now the important technology that we're
going to be talking about a lot
is what's called 16s metagenomic
sequencing
which is a technique that has been
fairly well established because of many
benefits
for micro microbiome studies
it is widely used to study microbiome
directly in its environment
and it focuses on the 16s
ribosomal rna that has to be amplified
with pcr
amplification the 16s gene sequences
contain
what's called hypervariable g regions
also known as
hvrs that provide specific
signature sequences that are very useful
for bacterial identification
in the taxonomy of all bacterial species
the benefit of amplification is tied to
the nature of sequencing
read length which can maximize the
effective
output from affordable sequencing
technologies
now we mentioned a hypervariable region
so hyper variable regions
allow us to understand how different
communities look at the different types
of microbial organisms that are present
now there's too much of a diversity to
really study those individually so
instead
we can characterize them by organizing
them
into operational taxonomic units or otus
so this is an operational definition
that is used to classify
groups of closely related individuals
otu classification can be done using
several different computational
approaches
hierarchical clustering algorithms
bayesian clustering
or phylogenetic analysis based on
multiple sequence alignments
once those otus are identified
as you can see in this example right
here and they are
categorized by some common variation
that is common to all the different
species that are present and carry this
otu
then we can apply mapping onto
databases and there are several
databases that have been
regularly updated and used in such
metagenomic research
one of these is the silva database which
contains
taxonomic information for the domains of
bacteria
archaea and eukarya it is based
primarily on phylogenies for small
subunit ribosomal rnas or the 16s for
prokaryotes and
18s from for eukarya taxonomic
rank information for arcane bacteria is
obtained from burglaries
taxonomic outlines and from the list of
prokaryotic names
with standing in nomenclature lpsn
whereas eukaryotic taxonomy is based on
the consensus views of the international
society of protestologists
taxonomic rank assigned in the silva
database are manually curated
and for comparison it was it was seen
that silva is one of the more reliable
consistent
and up-to-date databases compared to
some of the other ones
like the green genes the ribosomal
database
project or rdp and ncbi
so it's important to understand what
this taxonomy
allows us to see when we analyze data
applying mapping onto such databases
for example here you can see the
hierarchy of biological classification
many of the otus lack annotation
at the lower levels like species genus
and family
so a lot of times the characterization
of a community
can be comprehensively done at the
higher levels like phylum and kingdom
now in the phylum level we can start
looking at how
different microbial communities vary
between different
organs and here we're talking about some
healthy microbiota
found on the human body so you can see
here some examples of phylum
like firmicutes actinobacteria bacteria
deets
proteobacteria and fusobacteria and how
they
vary between some of the commonly
studied organs in the human body
now you can see for example the colon as
compared to the skin the colon contains
the majority of proteobacteria as
opposed to the skin which contains the
majority of
actin of bacteria we can look at it from
this level to understand
what might be the environment that is
caused by such
composition and we can study changes in
this
healthy composition across many
individuals
to determine any effect of common
changes
in health and pathology that is observed
on these organs now importantly
the bacteria are not the only
components of this microbiome
or the microbiota importantly we have
also
the viral which is actually one part of
the microbiome and constitutes
all of the organisms that inhabit us
including bacterial and archaeal
organisms as well as the microbiome and
other members of the mayo phenomena
such as protists and metazoans studies
of the viral
are also in their infancy because it has
only recently become possible to see the
virum in large sequence datasets
using advanced bioinformatics tools that
can detect relationships between
viruses despite their extreme nucleotide
sequence diversity
now the size of the mammalian viral is
not even known as opposed to microbiome
and bacteria
the viral composition is not really
that well characterized although our own
cells amount to similar quantities as
the bacterial members of the human
microbiomes
human feces alone contain 10 to the 8
viruses per gram additionally the
mammalian viral
is continuously updated to rapid
evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment
or in other mammals that we interact
with
now importantly we can also apply
metagenomic sequences
to understand presence and composition
of viral bacterial composition in a
sample so here you can see
some of the common sequencing techniques
that produce a
characterization of some of the common
prevalent viruses
that also play a major role in the
composition of the microbiome because
the microbiome
is a protective layer and controls the
replication of some of these
harmful pathogens but also in the
different diseases that they
cause now some of these viruses are very
prevalent
in cancers and they also represent an
important part of the interaction
with the human microbiome so what we
will talk
in the context of the program a little
bit is how
some of these viruses like the
epstein-barr virus
human papilloma virus and hepatitis
viruses
cause important cancers that are a
huge burden on the human well-being
and health so let's talk about a few
practical examples in the
program we will talk about each one of
these examples
in greater detail and so after i go
through these examples i think i will be
able to address some of your questions
in a little bit more detail based on
what the information that we present
here a big part of the human
microbiome project is the american gut
project so you can see here a link
let's actually take a look at this link
quickly together
so i'm going to just post this in the
chat
so we'll go to this american gut project
okay so it seems like their website is
down so let's instead
go here uh so you can see how
american gut is a very interesting
project because it actually involves not
just a comparison of healthy
and sick people but seeks to
characterize microbiome very
variability based on multiple factors
that are self-reported
by citizen scientists so essentially any
one of us can participate
in this american gut project by paying
for a small fee for sequencing
but essentially repeating the benefit of
comparing our own microbiome
and our self-reported traits like ethnic
background
the foods that we eat how often we
exercise
whether we get sick regularly or not and
really to try to establish
some common links between microbiome
composition and such traits across
a huge diversity of people now
importantly
this microbiome project is now expanded
well beyond
the us it involves such places like
canada
and even europe and any one of you that
is interested to participate
can follow through this publication to
understand how
these communities vary and what are some
of the important associations that are
emerging from the study of this
microbial composition
so let's take a look at an example this
is actually a report that
one might get from producing that kind
of sequencing so you get a kit
and you sample different areas on your
body
using these swabs sending them over to a
central lab
where that sequencing is performed and
based on the analysis of such sequences
you can see
how your sample compares to some of the
other samples that are already in this
database
now what we will do in the program is
take several samples like these
to produce a report exactly like this so
that will give you some hands-on
practical
work experience dealing with
samples that come from healthy
and sick people that have contributed
their own samples to this database
now another important area of research
is how does the specific microbiome
composition affect different areas
of normal subnormal and
clinical conditions in some cases like
gut microbiome
we can sample clinical patients and find
associations with clinical
conditions of the microbiome composition
changes
but in many cases it is very difficult
to have a controlled environment
where such changes could be studied and
a good example
is the link between obesity
which is a phenotypic condition the
microbiome
which is difficult to necessarily link
to this phenotypic condition anxiety
which is a physiological but more
psychological condition
and to really establish a link and so
to address this challenge there have
been a number of
animal models that have been developed
to really elucidate
the direct connection between microbiome
changes
and such conditions the way it was done
and we'll take a look at this kind of an
example in greater detail
is we'll take this publication that's
called obese type gut microbiota
induce neurobehavioral changes in the
absence of obesity
now the way that they performed this
experiment
is they took early young
mice at three months old that's when the
microbiome is being
developed they then reduced
the bacterial load so they really
reduced the composition the complexity
of the microbiome did some behavioral
testing
and developed a model where you can see
how different recipients
of microbiome composition from these
donors that were
at a young age established on a specific
diet
can lead to actual characterization of
changes in microbiome
and links to their behavioral changes
as well now the way such studies could
be done
is by employing what's called
bioinformatics
analysis pipelines so what do these
pipelines
actually look like the way it is done is
that at each stage
you get some samples and these samples
represent
a community that could be characterized
by operational taxonomic unit diversity
and composition so let's take a look at
how
this is done to take a look at a
practical example
we're going to be using the analysis of
16s
amplicon data which is a study that we
just described from that paper an actual
data set from that paper
where you can analyze sequencing data
using the data to pipeline
so to take a look at this practically
please go with me to
server.tdashbio.info
okay this is a platform that we commonly
use in
our analysis logic so what is important
to understand is not only how this data
is produced and what types of studies
are out there what types of data sets
are out there
but really to see how does the data
become informative how do we reveal
information
and what kind of information is it going
to be
so this is the platform that we use for
training but it's also a research tool
that you can use in your analysis
of metagenomic sequencing data now if
any one of you would like to get
a quick demo i'm going to do this to
just showcase what it would look like
but you can also request
a demo account from beeps in here on
chat and then you will be able to follow
along
so down here i'm going to just show you
this section the amplicon 16s 18s
section
and we have a demo pipeline here that i
will just briefly go through
so that we don't have to analyze the
data in real time so this is
pre-analyzed data
so this is what's called the data 2
pipeline and it is an important tool for
simplifying the diversity by
merging high quality reads into
operational taxonomic units
that are mapped onto a reference
database
and then we can visualize that
information using philosophy
so i'm going to create here a very
simple pipeline
that will look at hypervariable regions
v4 and v9 you can see this is the
16s ribosomal rna so there's v4
and here we have v9 right here these are
hyper variable regions that are commonly
used to characterize
diversity in metagenomic sequences
the data 2 pipeline as i mentioned is an
important tool
that allows us to remove all kinds of
artifacts that can lead to
false positives and false negatives in
the way that we
characterize the composition now this
noise
is an important challenge in all
metagenomic sequencing
so here what we will do is we will take
a few steps
to really reduce the noise and make sure
that we create cluster samples that are
consensus otus
chimeras and then use mapping onto a
database
by assigning taxonomy to these samples
after this is done we are going to
identify
relationships between these otus by
analyzing phylogenetic relationships
using
ape so what ape does is it
forms a relationship based on multiple
sequence alignments
of these otus and then we can visualize
this data
by using a commonly used package in r
called phyloseq so here you can see
differences in compositions
and what is useful in filoseq is that it
produces some
standard visualization tools and we'll
talk about
how that is done in just a second to
help us
understand the variability between these
different samples
so to illustrate what we will typically
get out of it
are several pdf files that allow us to
visually understand
what we have found
so first of all i am going to look at
the scores
of read quality so here you can see the
read quality
the read quality is important for us to
understand
what is the actual level at which
the cutoff of the threshold of read
quality
is done you can also
see the results so this quality of reads
is actually done by the data 2 pipeline
and then once we have high quality data
we can start
analyzing that using philosophy so here
we have the phylo seek results
so the phylo seek results allow us to
look at
composition what does this composition
actually look like
the composition here you can see it is
done by family so this is a very
good level of composition and you can
see how
we have diversity between different
samples and so here we have the samples
here we have the abundance or this is
proportional abundance of different
families
of microbiomes including some unknown
ones that were not
characterized this kind of an abundance
can actually characterize diversity
based on alpha and beta diversity so
alpha diversity
and beta diversity allow us to look at
composition within samples and between
samples this is not just simply done
based on the abundance about to use
but also on the phylogenetic
relationships between
individual otus representing
species richness or how diverse
each sample is and how that diversity
changes
between groups of samples so here you
can see
the chao one and the shannon metrics for
alpha diversity and you can see how
those samples
vary in those diversity matters as well
as you can see
right here right here you can see
beta diversity which is done by
non-metric dimensionality scaling
which is that which is showing us a real
clear difference
between the samples that are done on
regular diet that have been grown based
on regular diet
and those that have been grown on high
fat diet
really that illustrates how we can
understand
the relationship between microbiome
composition
and the relationship with a phenotype
that we can actually characterize or
study
using a psychological test
okay let me just give you a couple more
examples
and then i will open this up for
questions again
an important part of such studies has
allowed us
to understand how different types of
conditions
including changes in diet
and including in the changes in
treatment have led to important
discoveries
about the microbiome for example one
such discovery
was made on the effect of microbiome
changes in the composition and
alzheimer's disease so in fact
you can see here in 2019
china has approved alzheimer's disease
treatment that targets the microbiome
so these are very important new
discoveries that have been done
in the context of microbial studies
based on
a association with a human
samples as well as samples that were
designed in animal experiments
another important result of such studies
is the effect
of cancer therapy so anti-cancer
treatment modalities and co-medications
we know that they affect the integrity
of the epithelial
barrier they also affect the actual
microbial composition
so you can see here how the different
changes in microbiome that affect the
immune response
that affect the integrity of different
organs and the protective films that
these microbiota
form as well as the actual direct impact
on the immune cells involved in
responses
so as a result we can identify microbial
signatures as you can see here below
that actually will help determine
whether
a particular cancer treatment will be
effective
and to track the effectiveness of such
treatment
over time of the course of treatment
potentially changing
the course of treatment or seeking to
modulate
the microbiome composition to prepare to
kind of
prep up the patient for effective
consumption of treatment
for particular diseases okay
so these were just a few examples i know
that there are a lot of questions about
other types of examples that could be
done so let me focus right now on some
of the questions that you've posted on
the chat
pizza if you could help me sort through
the questions so i could respond to the
important ones yes uh sure elia
so we had uh one from shraddha earlier
so do the microbiome of normal person
differ from diseased one
yes so obviously there's a lot of
variability
between what we call normal people right
we know that normal people
consume different foods they grow up in
different
environments even drinking different
water
so all of those things change the way
the microbiome develops as was shown
in this example with animal models where
transplanted microbiota actually
led to specific types of changes in
behavior
now those would not necessarily
categorize a person as a non-healthy or
a clinically sick person
but it definitely changes susceptibility
to diseases
changes the response to different
pathogens and as we can see here
changes the response to different
treatments so obviously
there's a lot of diversity to sort
through before we define
whether there's an association with a
clinical condition
now some clinical conditions have very
clear-cut changes for example
irritable bowel syndrome or ibs
different other types of sensitivities
of the gut
more and more of such changes are weaker
links
so they're really just a component in a
complex systems biology
relationship between a clinical
condition
and the microbiome so i think we have to
put it into context if that answers your
quite
a question if not you can maybe clarify
now i do see that modibo here put a
question
privately to me so i will just read that
out
how can we simulate in silico the repair
genes interactions with mutated gene or
for dna
reparation and which server or
bioinformatics could do it
um so if i understand correctly the
question
uh the repair genes dna repair genes
uh and mutations in dna
is what the question is all about so
maybe a scenario or a project
example here is to think of cancer so we
can think of
cancer oftentimes caused by somatic
mutations somatic mutations are repaired
by
repair genes and so mutations and repair
genes
and accumulation of somatic mutations in
the dna eventually causes cancer
now how can we simulate
the interactions between the repair
genes
and dna mutations so i think that
you need to develop a mechanistic model
that really defines all of the
relationships but
um before you define that model that
model should be data driven so i think
the first
part of it is to really take some
sequencing data
that combines gene expression and
mutation data
so you can look at accumulation of
mutations or
presence or absence of particular
somatic mutations
and the expression of genes and really
the interaction could be studied by
what's called
multi-omics integration the server that
i just demonstrated
the server t-bioinfo
server.tbioinfo
a number of sections for both
multi-omics
integration so you can see right here
multi-omics integration that
seeks to take two different types of
omics data and study relationships
within
this multi-armored data set using
different approaches for example
integration based on part-time networks
or bipartite
networks or clustering and other types
of approaches so that's
one way to study the interactions
once you develop a mechanistic model
there are a number of
uh mathematical modeling tools that we
also have
and that typically involves mathematical
simulation so once a mathematical model
is developed you can simulate that model
now that's a very complex process of
actually
making that model first and maybe
testing the model prediction on data
so if you are interested in that we do
have a section related to that but i
think we would need to
understand a lot more what the actual
project
is about to uh to really help you
okay any other questions yes celia we
have one from dr
manov jain can there be temporal
relationship between
duration for which microbiome is altered
and development of disease for how
long microbiome should remain altered
so it's a great question i would assume
that question would be more directed to
a microbiologist i myself am not
a microbiologist i more
can address the questions about the
bioinformatics
component here so i think what would be
a good approach to try to answer that
question is to find a specific data set
and i'm actually going to get to that
point
in just a few minutes so maybe we can
[Music]
take the remainder of the questions and
just email them to us we would be happy
to continue this interaction after the
webinar
to really help you identify a project
examples
existing datasets and link them with
effective tools that will help you
try to find some answers to these
questions and
if you are a microbiologist and you're
interested in trying to
apply metagenomic sequencing data
analysis tools
to answer such questions i think there
are
a wide variety of publicly available
data sets and that's the exciting part i
think in silico studies and
computational biology studies that we
have access to such great
microbial data sets that we can analyze
so i will get to that
in just a second in just a few minutes
okay so we talked about a few examples
and again
thank you for your questions i think
these are excellent questions
i do want to mention that the program
that we are going to be launching on
november 17th
is going to be designed for those of you
that have such
questions and would like to work with
different types of data
including metagenomic sequencing and
other types of ominous data
to be able to answer such data such
questions that you have so let me talk
briefly
about this upcoming onyx logic
metagenomics program
that will be starting november 17th
the online program again is designed to
help students at as well as researchers
and faculty
to try and address such questions with
bioinformatics analysis so the objective
of the program
is to help you develop an independent
project
maybe trying to answer some of the
questions that you have already proposed
in this chat
leveraging the tools and the data
that we will discuss and develop
practical skills with so that anyone can
actually use them
so the program is designed to really
highlight the role of
big omics data that is shaping modern
biomedical innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision diagnostics
big data integration and machine
learning are transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative
algorithms allow for unprecedented
capabilities
with drug discovery drug design
as well as repurposing and so the
important part is that
these various types of omics data that
we describe in great detail
intracellular and intercellular
processes associated with common
diseases
they have to be analyzed to understand
understand the biology behind
host factors and microbiome composition
in our bodies in the environments that
we live in
to drive infection and cause deteriorate
deterioration of health to destabilize
the immune system
and lead to clinical manifestations of
disease
so these multi-omics data sets
require different approaches to the
processing
integration visualization and
interpretation
and the objective of the program is to
give you a sense of how these different
methods and
tools could be applied directly to study
microbiome or the host responses
to find links and associations with some
of the clinical data that we have
about patient interactions with their
clinicians
so the objective of the program again as
i mentioned is to provide
a platform for you to think about
find develop projects that are
independent and get some feedback
from participant experts in the panel
that will actually help evaluate and
help you refine some of the ideas that
you might already have
so really at the end of this program you
will be able to present the project to a
panel of
experts here we will bring in some
experts that have experience
with metagenomic sequencing data
analysis they will be able to help guide
prepare you and then evaluate your
project proposal
now the objective of these omics logic
programs is to provide you with a clear
perspective
on big data analytics machine learning
and artificial
intelligence so that anyone can try and
apply
a variety of different analysis methods
and to do that obviously it's very
important to have
access to curated datasets so what we
will do
in the context of this program is
actually look
at such public repositories like the
human microbiome project
the american gut project we will look at
different
disease specific metagenomic data sets
and a lot of the tools that you will
gain will allow you to effectively
search
ncbi the national center for
biotechnology information
and identify data sets that are ready
for
analysis our previous participants
have developed a number of research
projects together
in this program that have led to poster
presentations
publications grant applications for
those that are already in research
where you can leverage bioinformatics to
define some
interesting preliminary results and
those preliminary results can define the
way that you are
thinking about a particular research
question
so to summarize what we've learned today
is an important part in this emerging
field of microbiome research that has
far reaching implications for different
types of conditions that are both
clinical
psychological environmental and others
and for you to get started on this
journey we are excited to present
this six session program
this program is designed to help you get
started
if you are coming from a life science
background or you're coming from a
computational background
it's really designed to launch you into
this field of metagenomics
so let me describe this data this
program a little bit
to explain how you can join
and what you can take away from this
program
so first of all uh the link to the
program itself where you can see
in much greater detail all of the
different elements that i'm describing
now
is metagenomics.omixlogic.com
so this program itself we can take a
look here
together what it will cover
uh you can see the dates for this
program
a short overview of the program and here
you will see
some of the specific topics that will be
covered in each one of the sessions
as well as some of the asynchronous
resources
and some of the specific uh project
examples that we will go through
uh as well as some of the tools that we
do not have time to showcase
in this session because we're already
running
over time but you can definitely see
a lot more information about this
program on this link
now briefly going through some of the
sections and what will be
covered these are interactive training
sessions
we will talk about the specifics of the
program
and what type of resources that you will
get these include
big data analysis tools on the cloud
include
asynchronous resources that you can do
on your own time
interactive sessions where we will do
assignments together
including coding and running some
pipelines as well as some feedback from
experts that will help
guide your independent project and
refine your ideas
as you're trying to look for a
particular data we will talk in detail
about metagenomic sequencing and
guide you through an asynchronous course
where you can
learn about the individual terminology
and the different types of concepts that
are important to know
we'll talk about mapping on databases
and visualizing the sequencing data in
a cloud-based environment then we'll
talk about
how to study variability and composition
including some important
pipelines that are that are considered
to be the gold standard
like data two and kind two
we'll then talk about some of the
examples that we talked about
here briefly the american gut project
and the human
microbiome project as well as such
animal model studies like the microbiome
diet
and the association with the gut brain
access
finally we will help you develop an
independent project from publicly
available data sets that you will be
able to define
and develop a proposal potentially even
getting some preliminary results that
you can showcase
finally we will talk about some expert
feedback
for that project now
for the program we will leverage some
online tools and
in our next session when we do the
introduction to this program and that
will be a free webinar that all of you
are welcome to join
we will actually go through the
different types of the synchronous
materials
and discuss the scheduling and how to
get it started
so the program will start on november
17th
um i hope that this webinar is somewhat
informative and i was able to answer at
least some of your questions
we do have a blog post on the different
types of
applications of metagenomics in
different types of
communities like the skin the risk of
dementia
autoimmune diseases some of the ways
that you can culture and study bacteria
in the lab
so if beeps say you could uh place a
link to that blog so if any one of you
is interested in the different types of
projects that we will discuss
you will find those discussed on this
link
importantly i think that what we are
trying to establish here as a company
is not just the training itself and not
just providing you with
cloud-based tools that you can use an
important component
i think of these programs are the
community that we are building
and this community includes students
young faculty and researchers as well as
established
faculty and professionals that will help
you understand the applications of
metagenomics and microbiome research
in important basic and translational
research projects
so we always welcome those of you that
are interested
in omixlogic to join our social media
groups and one of them is called the
omixlogic
group on linkedin you can see here the
link
to the linkedin group in fact i'm going
to just
copy these and paste them here in the
chat as well as a facebook group
that you will see includes thousands of
participants from around the world
that will uh join some of the programs
that we have
and there are many different programs
that we have throughout the year
not just focused on metagenomics but
also focused on
other omnics fields as well as data
science skills
and specific research areas like
infectious diseases
or precision medicine thank you uh beeps
for uh the blog now i want to leave you
with a couple of links that i've
used throughout this presentation an
important link that you will find here
highlighted
is a full timeline of
milestones in human microbiota research
published by nature but you will also
find
some of the other links that i have
highlighted in this presentation
and these include a couple of articles
review articles on
the current and future topics in
metagenomics and microbiome research
as well as some of the tools that i
briefly mentioned
in this program and in this webinar
okay so as a conclusion
i'm happy to address any of the
questions that i might have missed
so please let me know if you have any
additional questions
about the metagenomic sequencing
microbiome research and human health
or the program that is upcoming
metrogenomics comicsologic.com
yes uh we have uh three questions
so one is from shraddha so her question
is i think a person with breast cancer
or any other cancer or disease
have some sets of microbiome niche
compared to normal ones
can it be used as biomarker or
predictive markers
by sequencing and finding out novel ones
okay so i think as i mentioned uh there
are
and maybe i'll use this opportunity to
maybe demonstrate this so
if we briefly go to um
sorry if we briefly go to ncbi
and i hope that this is going to be
useful for the other participants here
as well
um let me put this link in chat and
sure that most of you are familiar with
it
so here you can see on ncbi this is the
national center for biotechnology
information it contains a lot of
different repositories that you can
access
for free so in here you can do a quick
search right
so your question is about breast cancer
and microbiome so i'm going to just
search this
and see all the different types of
databases that contain information
on the relationship between breast
cancer and microbiome
so here you can see literature so
different publications
genes proteins clinical and
genomes so here what i would do is i
would go to this
bio project section the bioproject
section
is actually a definition of different
types of projects that have some data
associated with it so you can actually
take a look at the data so here you can
see for example
different types of brief descriptions
okay so here is a great example
of what your question is about
microbiota of breast cancer
tissue here you have human metagenome
comparative analysis of breast tumor
microbiome in black
non-hispanic and white non-hispanic
women gut microbiota profiling patients
with her2 negative metastatic breast
cancer receiving
metronomic chemotherapy the human tumor
microbiome
microbiome of a septically collected
human breast tissue and benign and
malignant disease
so you can see here that there is
a very big diversity of the types of
data sets that you can get
for example you have treatment
versus non-treatment you have different
patients maybe at different
types or subtypes of breast cancer maybe
in different
kind of compounding factors like ethnic
diversity and background
so you really have a variety of data
sets that
you can start looking at to ask these
specific questions
most of these will actually have a
publication associated with it or will
describe
how the data was collected and who was
collected by
and what it was collected for so really
you can
start looking at some of these examples
some of them are very recent
june 2020 so very up to date some of
them
might be a little bit older so here you
can see
a data set okay also 19th of august so
maybe these don't even have a
publication yet because they're
so recent let's take a look over here
weizmann institute of sciences in israel
so
here you also have april 2020. so this
is very cutting edge research i
encourage you to take a look at some of
these examples
and in the program we'll actually do
this kind of analysis together
um any other questions
uh yes elia so we have another
question from uh gaurav pardhikar
he wants to know if the environment
plays an important role more than the
genetics for development of the
microbiome
because the microbiome study is not done
much in respect to genetics
yeah i think that's an excellent
question so as we see
the microbiome develops in a much more
variable way than genetics and the great
excellent study for this
is the um the study that is called
um uh they are called twin
microbiome okay so there's a twin
uh microbiome study that
recently not so long ago uh has
shown how different factors actually
influence the development of microbiome
in genetically
uh in genetic twins and twins that are
genetically identical right and so that
i think directly answers your question
how the effect of environment
the effect of uh different preferences
for
food uh maybe how they grew up in
different environments
at different stages of their life really
has an effect
on the gut microbiome and i think that
is an excellent place to start answering
your questions so probably
i'll just paste the link to this
publication right here
there's a whole project here they have
clinical data microbiome data genetic
data so there's really
a lot of data here to go through if
you're interested in that topic
uh thank you elia and we have one uh
last
question so this one was from
someone whose name is still iphone so
the question is my research scope is on
lung brain microbiome axis using rsv
virus on animal model what
bioinformatics
approaches are the most suitable
so of course i would love to know a
little bit more about your research
project uh
you know just uh kind of taking that
information from that brief description
and as i understand you have a virus
so rsv is a respiratory virus if i
understand correctly
and then some of these viruses actually
replicate
in the central nervous system and i
might imagine that that is the
relationship between
the lung and the central nervous system
or the brain that you are referring to
when we talk about the gut brain axis
it's a little bit different it's the
effect of
how the gut microbiota can cause
changes in behavior or in psychology
so when you talk about a virus a
pathogen that directly
affects neuronal cells or has a path of
entry that goes through multiple organs
for example
intranasal cavity or lungs and then goes
somehow to replicate in the neuron
cells that's very different than the
effect
of a specific condition and perhaps
through
kind of this quorum sensing passed on
to other organs in the body so if you
are
looking at virology you're looking at
virus sequences viral replication
we do have a completely different
program called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
[Music]
okay so this is a a program that's
actually starting on november 9th
that i would recommend for you to
explore
here we do talk about the specific tools
for viral uh sequence analysis so viral
genomics
uh phylogeny of viruses evolutionary
studies of viruses we'll talk about
things like tissue tropism
and how specific mutations in viral
genomes could be associated with the way
that they replicate in different types
of cells
so i think that would be a more suitable
direction
if you're interested in that particular
project that i
if i understood it correctly
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining today's session
i am going to stop uh the sharing
if you do have any last questions uh
please do let me know
i would be happy to continue this
conversation
uh we will be starting this program
again on november
17th and we will have our first couple
of sessions are going to be again open
and free for anyone
so you will be able to join just to
evaluate and
be able to continue and asking these
excellent questions that we've had
in this session so again thank you for
joining and looking forward to seeing
you again
thank you so much elia for today's
session and thank you everyone for
joining today and for your questions
if you have more questions regarding any
related research that you would want to
carry out or you need any
help with that we are open to receive
your questions on marketing at pine.bio
and we will be reaching out to you
for any questions that you can have and
you can still request your access to the
t by info platform as well so we hope to
see you at upcoming sessions
and hopefully uh chat with a few of you
via emails so thank you so much for
joining today and thank you so much
india
for the wonderful session